hello welcome to this video playing yope
from that's bosnia is that Bosnian oh
yes this one is something entirely
different right tokelau a Bosnia has
this blue and blue and yellow but it's
different totally differently shaped
okay um let's go we hope 25 mm I don't
know kind of a kind of inventing stuff
here isn't going to be too a move here
this is funky that I get it back with
cream before I think it is but it is
risky check so how do I not lose the
Queen I don't want to lose the Queen I'm
getting myself into trouble here with
playing this and have knowing it and
don't have an idea about it might I
might get my queen trapped him Bishop d7
for potentially creature a four sets set
right one Wow 53 I can take the five I
mean
that's immensely immensely tricky to
play him oh my god i know i usually play
something else against the Trump but I
didn't want to do that again just wanted
to do something else then I with this
that's really not my style of playing
yeah this is probably the the issue
Queen f5 and he's got g4 even oh my god
yeah probably he just knows knows all
this and just has to play the stuffy he
knows I don't know 94 and now probably
Bishop d3 and you kind of ask yourself
what your next move is okay 96 is the
issue 95 takes cheeks I am now okay i
will get killed here and totally okay
god yeah so don't play this line if you
have no idea about it am I losing here
immediately probably yes but I'm not
entirely sure okay now i can at least
move the Queen which is which is kind of
reassuring maybe I can take here
actually is that possible
we should be true and then create a five
I don't know of course the SB should be
five and then i have to go King the aid
but okay jack that's just that's just
what happens here 96 looks funky Bishop
takes takes it might be good Bishop
takes pawn takes check 21 routine one
King c7 yes it's very serious option
yeah very serious option 96 we should
want eggs okay jack okay so I of course
and that's possible very very nice very
nice I didn't see it d 6 or what I will
see I only had two here I didn't have
okay I'm not checking made it
immediately this is this is really
really good um so here a d6 I'm not okay
and I can take it ok I can actually
check and look the aid check Bishop f5
maybe checking the rook
this was much worse at some point okay
it's probably not a bad decision but
still i mean if i take the seven here
what's going on I can go through here
look there okay okay okay so let's sound
bad kind of slow and recognizing things
here in this game but now I can take him
right and it's good i'm not sure why why
you needed to do that time morning i got
many things traded him but still what
are you doing to me that's it that gets
spooky all this tactic stuff
check
I was seeing some kind of major okay
doesn't really doesn't really work
hey it's going to check them
still cannot take check check what
shortly my time is quite low position is
now relatively easy winning with the
Yukon jack have time time time I've got
0 seconds i'm such a practical idiot
Jack Jack Jack Black for fix on time
just I need to have a second head to
kill his book well it's very stupid
losing games like that I mean I probably
losing in the opening and because it's
no idea and this it costs ages 2 to play
this I mean it's really funky with all
the Queen moves ok I mean at least the
curve shooter doesn't see an immediate
win for him it just took took a very
long time to play
yeah 96 as I said does win oh my god
this is very cool actually here i was
thinking of this and ok nice is kind of
dangerous yeah what should I computer
says white wins him but he actually has
something better he has this move and
this is a very very cool move now my
queen is attacked and if I move it then
he takes with check and comes the size
of flame yeah like him check check check
mate so that would have killed me
instead like this and yeah here after
the Queen trade I'm ok yeah ok now i'm
winning more better at least we should
be three whatever it doesn't really
matter this is a totally winning
position and i should win it with one
minute I mean check but he kept
irritating me check it's not much to
chat chat to say them what took me like
eight seconds here there's always like
one second time in check check I mean
technically this was was quite ok I'm in
here I have no seconds Jan yeah whatever
it's the problem he actually was was
that the opening cost so much time that
I wasn't able to to finish the game
properly I mean at the end TM and what
is that ran 50 and so you should really
lose on time on 50 and that that
shouldn't happen ok anyway thanks for
watching